[Music]
there you go Bobby Kelly in studio oh
hey we're here let's start the show off
on a nice now one of our friends is dead
here's a GoFundMe uh yeah well we should
we gotta plug it you know yeah you do we
love you I mean they're almost there
here's the problem with GoFundMe they
always no matter how much they do it
they do too low right you gotta just
drop a mill they're already at a hundred
grand if you put a mill you would have
got 500 Grand so does it stop like if I
give a thousand dollars it'll just not
do it it keeps going but when I look at
it I'm like look I I'm I'm out right you
did you got what you wanted the bar was
too low for the kindness they always put
the bar too low aim higher yeah Steve if
you don't know is our beloved uh head of
security at the comedy seller and uh
great guy was there 22 years yeah
Dante put this up but his cut is 40
and then another 10 goes to CAA yeah
daddy's gonna roll up on a new
motorcycle
he's gonna have a new earring like some
type of gazelle bone here a real Rhino
Tusk earring how does he do it every
time I show up at a club he's parked
insanely illegally and he'd never go
never gets a ticket he's got a giant
Jeep on jacked up tires that's how you
do it is that is that the secret 100 one
ticket pull up in a Hyundai and they're
gonna give you a ticket you pull up in a
a apocalypse vehicle and you look like
Mad Max Vibes for sure Mad Max five and
he has he literally has animal bones
sticking out of parts of his body he
does yeah he's an ex-pimp right yeah
he's an expert and a stripper he was a
stripper what dude he was a male
stripper wow he would smack himself when
he got out of line with his own cop yeah
that's crazy to be a stripper that's
like a crazy job I I gotta actually do
it once really what Young Bobby sexy
Bobby oh thank God
sexy Bobby was a stripper wow this this
girl who I knew was a stripper and we
used to tan together when I went tanning
sexy Bobby had to go tanning you gotta
go to Dan listen you gotta you got to
play the roll if you're gonna go in you
go in gym I'm gonna wear tight jeans and
a wife beater and not tan yeah you don't
be pale with the veins yeah I'm gonna
have tan arms and then some Farmer's
[ __ ] so you lay in one of the bugs with
the little things on your eyeglasses I
like the little things I went in get
those cancer eyes I manned up and two
little dots on my butt I don't know if
you know when you go tanning when you
you your bone presses against a dozen
Tans we have a little all tanning people
have two little dots and then white dots
on their butt yeah we used to tan
together she came out one day she goes
can I ask you something I was like what
she goes um I dance I strip and uh I do
private stuff but sometimes they want
bachelorette parties and stuff and I'll
I'll do we'll do like a uh I like they
want a couples thing or would you do
that with me I was like did you just ask
me to strip wow wow nice that's a
compliment it wasn't can you think about
it I I for two seconds my Robin Patrick
Kelly I don't have the peace I don't
have a piece to be stripping the Irish
curse yeah plus I get back then I got
hard too quick
I just got a heart at anything so I just
I would just show up just with a rod
just a like a five and a half inch or
just sticking out of my little golemag
g-string yeah that's not terrible no
it's not I mean you're right that's all
right that's not bad when I was a kid we
had a strip club and they would if you
turned 18 they'd bring you on stage and
all the girls would dance on you and if
you got a boner you'd have to pay but if
you didn't get a boner you were gay yeah
you had to pay later in life to your
father you ought to suck the owner's
dick that's how I met Mateo well that's
like you go to those uh remember
Bachelor Party the two strippers in
bachelor party oh yeah
[Music]
by the way we had his gin here Aviation
gin and when Phil Hanley was on he's a
gin snob and he oh yeah I'll only drink
uh I only drink monkey 87 monkeys 47
whatever yeah I only drink that so we
literally got Aviation gin that bottle
that's all we had and we just put a fake
uh sticker of monkey 47.
I've never seen this uh bottle before
and we're like we never told him yeah
because he's an idiot he just drank your
in they were like this is a great drink
we're like hey you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
he's a fake snob there you go first of
all Canadian pack uh yeah I mean attack
at this point oh Patrice
oh these are all dead people we're
almost on there
I was just about oh Bobby
you have a half a picture of Keith
he was booked a month ago he's still not
here
he's working this area of town sucks I
know you got a deal or whatever it is I
don't know what happened this to get
here if you don't live in this city
stinks the train is you can't take the
train you'll get murdered I should have
[ __ ] just taken the goddamn answer
we're taking the train back clearly yes
come back another day I took a loan out
to park the car over here how much was
the parking it's a hundred something
bucks I got it down to 55 I gave him a
hand job
young Bobby dude yeah
he had uncircumcised do I knock him down
another ten I was like that's gross I'm
not doing that he was like okay dude
look at this yeah that's America that's
American Indian Bobby right now Theo
Vaughn looks good yeah
yeah that's sexy Bobby a little after
that though when I have my um and you
took it down I think what I don't know
you know you know what the seller photo
the sexy one oh that's a hot body why
are Bobby's still there no no SD likes
to rearrange well I got you know where I
I love doing the E Street Band what is
that that's uh rock and roll Bobby toxic
Rock dude what about eyebrow Bobby
pointing
eyebrowser who is that that's it
you get your beard like that that is
dude it took a lot if you [ __ ] it up
you have to start over too wow did you
do a switchblade yeah it's so nice yeah
look at that I'm hanging myself because
that's like the hot dude in prison there
oh yeah you got green skin look at those
two phones I do I do have great skin I
think my great great grandmother [ __ ]
the Filipino woman nice yeah how many
women do you think you've laid in this
day yeah how many have you bedded at the
cellar Bobby yeah oh my God
[Laughter]
no no way that's a good image that's
real Bobby oh no that's real that's
right I was that fat I was gonna die you
were gonna die I went on the wall and
you should be how do I hope I want old
Bobby dead that's not a doctor that's
you need to go to a doctor yeah yeah I
did and go to you and get my stomach
thank god dude was that scary will I get
my stomach yeah yeah tell us everything
no the operation was terrifying because
you know you want to do it I did it
tried to do it for years I couldn't do
it so finally I was like all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this thing but it
takes a while you have to you can't just
go in and get it some doctors do that
but if you have a doctor that's like
yeah come in Tuesday I'll cut your
stomach up you're don't do it right the
answer is his own phone yeah and it's
it's there's a lot of people
I don't want my doctor knowing my like
following me on Instagram but um
there's people that have done it that we
it's like being gay because all these
people have done it that I know but
they're not out I came out good for you
thank you very much I can't wait for you
to do it
um it's the same with the hair plugs
like the hair [ __ ] right soda or Mateo
are very open about it oh yeah soda got
them oh yeah he talks about it
okay okay okay you're that guy that
outed the kid by accident growing up
he's a Jew
I feel bad for Mateo I think I was the
cause of Mateo getting hair plugs no no
no I'm a tail was as bald as you are
well he was going one day we were
getting it notice it we were getting it
the way it was yeah so one day we were
getting into it and I was like listen
buddy your hair is going you gained
eight pounds you're out of it you're
done I made it like this
you did say that I felt bad about that
too he's such a funny guy and a hunk
he's a Hunker you're a perfectly uh
she rolled me every 20 minutes in the
crib I swear to God really every 20
minutes you're supposed to roll the baby
if you don't if you just let the baby
sit I don't know about that if you ever
let if you see a dude with a flat back
head his mother didn't care about him
she just was smoking cigarettes in the
front porch talking to Helen
I got a waterfall back here let's go
straight off a cliff your parents didn't
care about you yeah your mom does give
great head but yeah she gets mediocre
pump for these beard you what are we
drinking uh I hope it's [ __ ] good
espresso martinis oh god wow looks great
breakfast great I mean you this guy's
real oh he's a big solid I mean look at
that [ __ ] apron man he paid money for
that [ __ ] yeah he's got he's got
steampunk jewelry and everything right
there's leather on that holy [ __ ] yeah
what's going on with the Rings there
what do those say they don't say
anything they just say don't [ __ ] with
me oh all right well there you go
[ __ ] with each other than a gun in
April you can't [ __ ] with a guy with a
hairline like that that is a that's a
beautiful Russian head of hair that is
legit are you Russian oh perfect this is
great
this guy's gonna spice things up yeah I
dare you to say you don't like that
drink you got the little bean in the top
too the the garbage no that's great man
well done
fancy thank you very much now what do
you do for the rest of the time to
Bobby's Health okay let's let's talk to
Bobby's Health hey thanks for being back
out check out his new special kill box
on Louis ck.com yes one of the funniest
dudes in comedy one of the hardest
please check this out Louis ck.com oh
[ __ ] that's so good there's cinnamon
what an ass oh my God anybody who
supports me it tastes like cake
delicious
you would have been distracted too this
is delicious really alcohol and food
this is what you want to do to me
so sweet
that is ridiculous
wow I'm gonna need another one oh yeah
Mark sees Liz last night the celery is
like do you think you can handle day
drinking as he's saying it she's got an
aperol Spritz this time
yesterday she was drinking a pint glass
Martini oh yeah and it was not her first
I don't think no and you were in the
basement yeah
I gotta come back I have you know I have
more at the cellar in over a year what I
have been on the seller stage in over a
year whatever is this because of the
operation no no no no no because I I I
went away for the summer uh I've been on
the road you know I got a family yeah
it's like I go and I do Tuesdays you
know and I don't need to you know Friday
and Saturday night but on the roof of
months and then you come home and you
want to spend the Friday and Saturday
covet [ __ ] and ruined me yeah up until
then I was I was there at least yeah
three times a week on weekends if I had
a weekend off I'd be there at least four
or five shows I I lost like I don't even
know how to be funny anymore like I
don't know how to write a joke I have a
bunch of things that I write down but I
don't know how to take it
to I don't know how it becomes a joke
anymore come on you'll get it right back
I know two two three times you just put
out a special I but I did a special but
it's I have nothing left yeah but that's
how you always feel after a special
let's just put out one out too yeah it's
the worst feeling in the world I got
gigs coming up and now the the curve
here is good I think it's a good
motivator it's good to have nothing
because you have to figure it out you
have no choice but to figure it out yeah
I think I guess so I mean but it's a
[ __ ] like I gotta go this weekend to
Cleveland and it's like hilarities
hilarities top five Club in the country
great about five I think it's a great
Club all right first one we're not we
don't count
sellers clubs I'm talking like Road
clubs Side Splitters I was losing the
mix solid some would say top five Bobby
loves great gloves I love it
I love I love Side Splitters but
hilarities is like like it's Comedy
Works color is great Comedy Works I
would say but the Comedy Works in Denver
yeah yeah but she don't work me no more
so I gotta take her out of myself so
she's gone I love Wise Guys I don't know
isn't that weird I have no idea yeah
that is the worst I mean work there
consistently great Club was cool but
then it's funny because we're all gonna
have beef with one of these clubs I love
Madison
top five yeah yeah there's got to be in
there just top five okay top five top
five but then there's a couple sleepers
like uh Utah I love Utah what is that
one called that's a great Club Wise Guys
the [ __ ] man Wise Guys Wise Guys a
great Club the Tempe Improv is solid I
don't know I just did CB live and I
liked it oh really I really like that
stand up live I love all those I like
those Street clubs That's All Brands we
won't have balls let's talk about the
top five suck clubs right now
I remember a club I did called loonies
with two e's Colorado Springs wow one of
those clubs all weekend all week the guy
was like you gonna drink and I was like
I'm just I'm not feeling great he's like
come on have a beer you [ __ ] and I was
like all right fine so I started
drinking then he hands me a bill for all
the drinks that's safe to happen to me
I'm working the club yeah funny farm in
Youngstown Ohio suck my ass
that guy up he up sold me he's like you
gotta get the swordfish and he's like
here's a good wine that goes with the
swordfish I'm like okay you know I'm the
comic here and then he gives me a bill
for 200 bucks no way oh [ __ ] that was
like half my my pay Jesus Christ
Youngstown Ohio famous for their
swordfish
[Music]
what is that I any club with the guy's
name in front of it Vinnie brand
[Laughter]
nah stress factors yeah not Bridgeport
but oh that one holy [ __ ] there's if you
do Bridgeport Stress Factory at least
one show you're gonna get near attacked
there's gonna there's gonna be heckling
that borders on the points I mean I got
chased off stage in Bridgeport
Connecticut really at the little Bijou
Theater someone chased me off the
[ __ ] stage
at Vinnie's Club no is it a different
venue but it's like that's what the
bridgeport's top oh dude it's on it's
coming back it's not cohesive camera
that camera it's not coming back
guess what Connecticut Bridgeport you
you're what you are you're like my
mother you ain't never gonna change
that's it it's a man who's in therapy
right there yeah
it's not coming back it's not coming
back I don't care we Brew houses they
think they had a brew house and a nice
breakfast place with lesbians right it's
a Town's coming back that only happens
in New Hampshire okay that only happens
in the woods in Vermont yeah you're
working with New Hampshire is like a
cute little City Christmas is great yeah
it happens in woodsy towns yeah you
can't take an urban city yeah that fell
down you can't make Detroit you can't
take a couple gays and three lesbians
and make Detroit have a big comeback
yeah they could save a neighborhood but
not a city yeah you can sit in it with a
piece of pizza right you could save a
certain section Detroit Pizza yeah but
you can't walk out the door you have to
get right into your car yeah
let him get shot yeah you can't yeah
it'd always be the always be the first
person to walk out never be the middle
person like snakes the middle guy gets
bit yeah dude when you come out of a
place in a bad neighborhood get to the
car all right be the second or third guy
because that's the guy that like I get
go go go go go go yeah I think the first
person yeah right another first yeah no
no no no when you're outside and you see
a gang of kids or something like that
they're gonna notice right they're gonna
be like yeah man [ __ ] that what the [ __ ]
what's this [ __ ] you're by there at the
car I'm talking about what's going on
they're gonna go to you hey hey and
you'll go what huh come here what and
you
why why we uh we just walk over we ever
have somebody do that some [ __ ]
lunatico come here for a second you walk
over what I've been there
because they don't have they don't have
they've never been beaten up it doesn't
it doesn't in their head they're not
like this guy might need some help right
did you ever do that when you were a kid
like hey hey come here and then kick the
[ __ ] out of someone 100 yeah really
that's why you know it's the middle and
I feel I still feel I still feel bad
about because let me just say this I got
beat up a lot I got really abused by
kids a lot I got beat up all the time I
used to have to hide in sixth grade I
would I was full we were all wrestling
one day and one of the kids got hurt and
he told his older brothers that were in
seventh and eighth grade oh [ __ ] they
all would every day for months I would I
would have to they would dismiss us I
would go to the bathroom and hide look
out the window and you'd see the kids in
the bushes waiting for me and then I'd
hide under the stairs until like three
and then I I'd make my way home every
day I walked home with fear like I was
gonna get killed yes yeah until seventh
grade and then seventh grade this kid
used to I mean I just get you know
picked on bullied and there's one blonde
kid it's always like a oh it's a ginger
you know yellow teeth and braces you
know that [ __ ] Christmas Story
douchebag yeah the white trash yeah it's
always that yeah that just Irish [ __ ]
right uh he got me in the hallway but I
broke my wrist and I had a cast on my
wrist oh
uh and you broke it hitting him no I
broke my wrist playing
yes he got me in the hallway I was going
to the bathroom and he got me in between
like the stairs and then there's the
door and then the hallway to the to the
class oh my profit
so uh yeah he got me in there and I I I
got so
so it all just came out I just started
beating the [ __ ] out of him until it was
bloody and he was crying and I walked
away and I go don't ever [ __ ] with me
again no but I went back to class and I
was just shaking and then over the PA
you hear uh anybody with a cast on their
right arm please report to the office so
I went to the office there was like two
other kids with cats crying and I walked
in with blood all over my house like I
did it whoa yeah that's a tough lineup
right there to get out of yeah yeah no I
I did that stuff and then I hung out
with kids I mean the kids I hung out
with I was 13 hanging out with 30 year
olds damn and I was hanging out at parks
with these I mean drug addicts
I was like Epstein her space yeah which
one's he gonna pick I was just watching
yeah dude I got I got beat up a lot we
used to drink we're not at my Park we'd
have potion night so uh the oldest is
like Kevin Spacey that's actually Bill
Cosby
they would um the guy would go down
everybody would give all your money a
dollar five dollars whatever you give it
to the big guy Mikey Katz he would go
down 30 year old guy he'd go down and
buy mudslide mixes all kinds of mixed
drinks they called the potion he would
come back and you get cheese cups and he
would mix all these like you he was you
except he murdered people uh not that
you don't murder people I understand
he's killed a few hooks your [ __ ]
John wickbeard
but uh he would make drinks and he'd
give you a drink and he'd walk around
and when he'd go here's how we know how
you had a drink you had a truck it
what's a cheese cup cheese cup Red Cups
oh like a red Solo
well that's what they were for back in
the Italian uh delis they would put
grated cheese in those
uh so we call them cheese cups look
cautious Bakery had the cheese cups and
if you didn't drink your drink he'd
[ __ ] you'd get punched in the face
what did he say to me here's how we know
how we'd all have to just drink when I
was in you how as much as it was cult
I'm 13. shrugging down these drinks and
if he looked in your cup and saw a
little bit left he'd wrap you right in
the head these are the guys I hung out
with right he was 30. 30 yeah and then
other people in this group were like how
old were they 18 20 25 we we hung out
this park uh at night during the day it
was a regular park for kids at night it
was our little gang or whatever not gang
but it was all the Italian kids hung out
there and we would hang out and just
drink and do drugs all night and and
[ __ ] with other [ __ ] with people you
know yeah if you walk through that park
at night it you were it was an it was a
scary thing are you in touch with any of
these people still no once in a while
one of them they came to the cellar two
of them came to the seller one night and
they were [ __ ] trash
[ __ ] Barbie we saw your [ __ ] names
what the [ __ ] and I got him in the side
guys you got to calm down I will calm
down do you [ __ ] here dude yeah and I
got him I said stand in the hallway they
watch me go up and they're like what the
[ __ ] they were nuts and they're like we
gotta go they didn't go they were like
we gotta go we're getting some they were
doing drugs and all [ __ ] up but yeah
they're walking up to an old lady finish
that drink
I mean dude they taught me at I think uh
11 no 12 how to drink alcohol like you
would get a pint or a half a pint of
SoCo and they uh this guy Jake gagliotti
taught me how to one sip it so you drop
your tongue so the that's how it doesn't
it
well I taught him
this is very similar
yeah yeah but if you drop your tongue it
doesn't hit your tongue you don't taste
it you don't gag
one sip uh uh a pint half I could do a
half a pint of my drink was Alan's 101
Petman Schnapps and a racket oh my God
what I would have said you were 13 go
easy I guess so but she stopped his
heart I'd rather love it no but schnapps
is sweet like when you can't keep snobs
saying peppermint schnapps I had a
saying uh Allen's 101 a w pleasure W
fund W Vision with Allen's 101. nice and
we would thank you and then uh
kid what are you doing here you got a
future in ad sales yeah you're a poet
yeah I remember that we and I used to
drink Wild Irish Rose what is that
that's why they call bum juice very
cheap uh it's like um it's whiskey and
wine mixed yay oh my God yeah but you
get a Galaxy
250. right so when you're 13 and you you
know oh it's like Mad Dog yeah it's mad
dog Mad Dog 2020. same thing therapy I
hate that [ __ ] but get you that right
there I used to get that and I would
hillbilly it I would just whip it on my
shoulder drink drink half of it be
[ __ ] up for the night
I remember yeah I drank a lot of that
[ __ ] right remember the kids who would
do the peppermint schnapps and just pour
Hershey syrup in it and make a
Peppermint Patty no I didn't know that
was [ __ ] disgusting but it tasted
pretty good I don't know but then you're
like did I just get drunk on peppermint
it's like you feel horrible of course
that's all sugar but it's dude it's it
tasted pretty good what's that drug that
you take that uh what's that drug you
take and you don't get a hangover that
doesn't or heroin
you don't feel the heck yeah you don't
feel any pain no regret you just keep
going it's great I feel I hate myself
the day after these oh yeah and the day
before yeah but I saw heroines up in the
village I saw like a couple heroines uh
last night oh they are everywhere
they're doing it I got out to do Jim and
Sam a couple weeks ago and the guy was
just doing it two dudes just shooting up
right there at the parking lot yeah on
uh ninth f it was open
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah heroin's up it's all up it feels
like old New York again Subway slasher a
guy at McDonald's with the [ __ ]
Hammer it's getting wild out there yep
it was a stampede at the Halloween
parade there's a bunch of guys take
their dick out
it is it's got an energy back I know
it's a little dangerous but you do feel
like it's kind of fun it does feel like
a video game down there it's GTA it's
not fun no I mean no I mean I understand
because I was here in the 90s yeah and
it was still [ __ ] up
um
it's like that again but I think it's a
little worse than that yeah because back
then we had Giuliani yeah who was
literally just setting up a mobile cop
unit at Washington Square Park really
yeah and we've got so bad though with a
Bloomberg they were giving out tickets
for being too loud what they went too
far yeah it was a loud ticket this is
now the opposite end of that Spectrum I
mean literally like on Bleaker Street
it's just dudes just needles in every
part of their body yeah just heroin
nodding yeah they they break into my
building all the time really all oh
that's scary
what happened in your building what
there was someone in the building
recently that you saw yeah there was
they're like all the sellers are
connected in those old tenement
buildings so someone went in like two
blocks away and came out on the kitchen
at Carbone and was like what's up whoa
that's hilarious they're like rats
they're just popping up everywhere yeah
me and Billy burrow lived on 97th I
think in 97 or 98. and I we would come
out on our stoop in the morning and I
there was a regular chicken just [ __ ]
and underneath those stairs and she'd be
like don't worry baby I'm gonna pick it
up and she would she looks like a dog
would just scoop it up with her hand and
take it with her and I'm like thank you
she's wanted a little cubby hole to take
a [ __ ] yeah she didn't want to do it
between you know two Buicks so you
should have invited her in oh my God
yeah Billy used to hang out we used to
do our laundry in the projects
like two blocks up we'd have to go on
the projects to do our uh seventh and
what 97th between the third and Lex oh
yeah yeah
I mean taking the train home from the
silly to walk the acid Place wait seven
hours yeah and take the local I mean
there was no AC trains back then
96. oh yeah there you go 96 feet yeah
96th Street walk Oakland Square Bodega
grab a little treat and then go back
over the stoop that was dangerous over
there I thought you guys lived in the uh
kitchen no the Italian Little Italy no
we lived in Hell's Kitchen I'm Billy
moved to Hell's Kitchen Joe DeRosa moved
in with Billy and I bought an apartment
on 47th in Hell's Kitchen uh-huh and uh
we lived there for I lived there for a
long time was it gay then because it's
super good it's newly what do you think
I moved there for
my wife was hot
Hell's Kitchen is pretty newly gay I
mean it's not not anymore now it's
families it's like oh really trying to
yeah it's healthy is that where you live
very friendly yeah yeah but I mean I see
a gay flag
still gay okay oh it's gay I had a gay
club across the street from my house
which I had a joke of my ACT about where
I said uh if that was a regular guy
banging every night Tony you [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] in the car the gay club is so
quiet you don't even hear him every once
in a while the door opens like you spin
me
and that's it I remember that bit I
remember thinking about that like back
in the day I felt bad me and Patrice one
night Patrice would drop me off uh some
nights and we pulled up one day and uh
in front of us we felt so bad about this
but in front of us there was uh a car
just rocking just someone's [ __ ] in
this Toyota the windows were steamed and
it was rocking and then this old guy
just stuck his head up and looked around
and then this young little twink was
like looking around me like oh [ __ ] so
we called the cops what
not because they were gay we didn't
realize like we felt bad we just called
the cops to [ __ ] with him as a joke so
the cops just the cops pulled up like
somebody's having sex and blah blah blah
and they pull up and they walk up to the
thing and they knock on the window and
he looks in and he just spins around and
went back into his car
but then they got out we were like ah
this old dude was getting some nice dick
yeah and we [ __ ] it up we were like we
felt we almost talked to him like hey
man we're sorry we did it your [ __ ]
blocks yeah we cocked we literally [ __ ]
blocked these guys I felt bad but
[ __ ] dude it was a different time go
get a room right I don't [ __ ] in the
bathroom a good car bang every now and
then it's fun this is my favorite one
you ever see meat well he Sparks over
Rodney Dangerfield he walks up to a
couple making out of the Dance Floor he
goes here she'll get it go you two
should go get a room then he walks up to
a fat couple dancing goes here too
should go get a warehouse that's a great
joke
yeah but that street I lived on had a
crazy house across the street from it
and they would the they would uh now
those guys are on the street but they
would walk around the street all day
long just screaming [ __ ] and yeah yeah I
confronted a guy one time because he was
just like screaming at me and I was with
my wife and he's like what the [ __ ] are
you I'm like shut the [ __ ] up then I
called the place I go you guys out front
and they were like hello I'm like the
guy they're like hello they were just
[ __ ] with me you know he's probably
getting six bucks an hour he's like
hello
and I'm like there's one of your people
home front [ __ ] and I started to get
you know crazy I was like dude [ __ ]
with citizens I use the word citizens
and all of a sudden he went hello
I was like it might have been one of the
guys the crazy [ __ ] answered
the phone but if it was the staff at
what were you laughing at that
that's a fourth hello
laughing at the same time because now he
I didn't want to give up I wanted to get
him yeah and then he went hold on it
just never came back so I called again
and he went hello oh dude I I had a I
missed a years ago I did a thing I
booked a flight on something called
CheapOair I know Chipotle it used to be
so it's not Expedia it's cheaper because
you'd get connect flights sometimes but
they'd be different airlines so if you
missed the flight you're rolling a dice
neither airline's accountable you're
just [ __ ] so I remember doing a
festival in Grand Rapids I missed the
connect flight I'm freaking out I go to
complain uh I think it was Delta and
they're like we're not doing anything
and the guy just he's just laughing at
me because he's like cheap O'Hare yeah
and I was like [ __ ] you dude I was so
mad and he just kept looking at me like
this like
and him just holding that laugh I saw I
got me yeah I was at like 583 bucks and
I was still [ __ ] I was like man it's
pretty funny just like if I take myself
out of this it is pretty funny how dumb
I am yeah CheapOair Jesus Christ got you
there but it is funny when they get you
at the airports those people are
professional at [ __ ] making you snap and
then stepping back I mean they have no
Poker Face better than wives because
yeah I don't know why they are holding
all the chips there's nothing you can do
they literally reap like TSA and then
they'll have you arrested there's
Federal [ __ ] they have to do is get you
to swear don't threaten them once they
get you to swear it doesn't take much
once they get to go you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah I'll [ __ ] you're done you're
never all there by a bunch of people
yeah that's all their goal is is to go
and and they do with it's all tone it's
like you it's like your wife or you
might help you excuse me I'm sorry oh no
that's fine you can do that is it fine
you [ __ ] do you know what it it's the
head tilt because I do it I literally do
it no it's the it's the it's the waiting
it's this at the airport where they're
like this one second
please and you know she's not doing
nothing just hitting buttons yeah I
missed my first flight ever yeah uh
coming out of skank Fest no I had first
class coming out of skank Fest you were
the only one I went to I got the bump
I got your seat then I I was so mad hey
Juggalos walking right past you right a
lot of fingerless gloves
this just happened I just happened I get
skank Fest was awesome yeah it was so
good it looked amazing I heard it it was
so it was the best one of the best
festivals I've ever been to the way it
was though the way it was set up the
rooms were all connected but it was huge
outside and it was awesome the clip of
you Norden hotel and everyone I mean
that looks so fun can I just say though
the most respectful amazing comedy fans
right ever the best the best I mean I
went to that show that you did
um with Tony Woods a tell the Legends
the Legends show and boss but he hosted
he was not a legend
he's just like literally
not one person filming not one they
don't not one and I'm standing and like
that's like you know I see that [ __ ]
like I can't turn it off they're the
best fans easily because they listen to
the podcast they they're more
sophisticated fans yeah
from us talking about what we kind of
what a good fan is or we they've kind of
I cool I can do that and those fans are
the best I had such a great time I I I
get in I the car comes I get to the
airport I go to the I have the uh
Platinum so I have the Centurion Lounge
whoa right which is never been in there
dude they got [ __ ] risotto I mean I
mean it's not you know
I don't know about that Centurion Lounge
in Vegas
was not everything I hope for and more I
feel like we're married right now I mean
you're really just jumping I know I'm
trying to build the story go ahead we're
going I'm going from [ __ ] skank fast
fans Uber came Centurion loud we're
building yeah and you just [ __ ]
you're not missing the flight either
yeah I'm getting there but I had [ __ ]
my my [ __ ] comedy wife
the eggs were a little runny [ __ ]
yourself
you got a lot you got a lot of Comedy
husbands I
um so I get I I'm in the lounge I take
American Airline uh which I hate I do
Delta horrible Airline here's racist
here's why they're [ __ ] terrible yeah
on the app Delta rap it says boarding
departure yes on American Airline it
says departure land
oh I don't give a [ __ ] when I get there
I want to know when I need to be at that
stupid gate to get on before all these
[ __ ] Savages yeah start panicking for
overhead space and they close the door
on you and they close the door I looked
at 8 50. it's that was departure I show
up 8 50. oh the plane's still there oh
and she's going
you know that and get new keyboards by
the way we don't need that right it's so
loud I mean get an Apple keyboard what
is this 1997 the Gateway yeah they want
the click they like it they want to go
old-fashioned it's annoying hear that
oh it's so annoying and they're just
typing in this guy is a piece of [ __ ]
he's on Facebook I'm gonna make him snap
[ __ ] him [ __ ] all his family I hope he
never sees his kids again so it really
is annoying I go
I go the planes right there can I just I
stop I stop begging you know you beg
first can I please and then you then it
goes into lying I gotta meet my my kids
he's got cancer to make a wish he just
lost a leg and a bull fight
so no sir I can't no 15 minutes it's
right there it's they just open the door
I'm here they love it they live for this
she looks up she goes I already gave
your seat away
[Applause]
my stomach first class seat
so uh you know Dave Smith's sitting
there like
I get more
she starts controlling the situation
more she knows the powers in her and she
goes back to the keyboard she starts you
know typing and looking up every once in
a while sir I can try I can try to get
you on the next flight because now I'm
pissing her off now so I'm like oh so I
gotta go I gotta swallow it I gotta
swallow it or attack her face yeah biter
Achilles off right I gotta I gotta
really maim her so she'll never forget
you either have to hit her with a smile
or you have to say is your mother a
piece of [ __ ] too yeah you have to pick
one yeah you have to pick one you have
to do that so is she White
no she's uh you hope for white just so
there's not an extra weirdness you don't
want there to be like a racial barrier
you heard Mark here first American
Airlines only hire white people yes
I'm just saying if she's black and
you're yelling at her it's a different
look yeah what are you gonna say about
Jews Jesus Christ
um I don't know what she was I think she
was Asian if that matters all right
Asian's fine you can hold an Asian
nobody cares about that he's trying to
[ __ ] muffle you out right now
you know what I'm talking about also
that glass is still up at the airport so
you have to do the [ __ ] thing where
you yell through the uh the hole there
what airport are you at what San
Francisco
it's a little dicey that's gone
bulletproof glasses all right all right
yeah she and then she puts me on the she
puts me on the wrong flight she puts me
on a flight that left Sunday thank you
so she [ __ ] me totally up she [ __ ]
up I was good no she [ __ ] me again
because I was being an [ __ ] thank you
she put me on a wrong flight so I called
Dawn panicking I'm like I gotta go I'm
going to Austin I'm going to do uh sugar
and Rogan oh you can't miss that so I'm
like I gotta go I gotta get there I'm
such a I'm gonna lied about my kid
having [ __ ] you know and then come on
Vogue and she's like okay
I know that's a bigger deal
she's never heard of your son
will you talk about the benefactors of
ginseng please bring that up I love elk
and alien dude I had the same thing
happen to me on American Airlines they
[ __ ] me it was when I was coming from
Rogan and I was flying to go from uh
Austin to Vermont so we had to connect
in Philly and I know I'm not going to
make the connection like the the
flight's on the ground too long so I
Sprint to the gate and as I get there
the woman shutting the doors ice cream
please don't shut it and I she looks at
me and goes I'm sorry and shuts the
[ __ ] door I was like why no
[Music]
airport airport Behavior
I put my foot in the door once and the
lady looked me in the eye and she goes
if you don't move your foot I'm calling
security and I was like come on it's not
closed yet gee she got me what is the
clothes thing it's just a made-up what
is it is it a Minecraft and it's like
another Universe happen why is it with
the clothes [ __ ] thing once they
close the door like what is that is it
no but it's before that is either
resident genius
it does look like it right it is
like the guy in the closet and Real
Genius
pull him up too while you're at it let's
get that visual oh damn Salamanca yeah
now you're frazzled him he can't I can't
Google wait I'm gonna get you guys the
new shirt I have [ __ ] the check spot
yeah
we gotta get we gotta get rid of the
[ __ ] show people if you don't know
what the check spot is it's when they
drop checks while a comic is on stage a
comic the comic the headlines they paid
for us there he is oh there you go I
always wanted that guy oh that's funny
dude they they they the guy they hot
they flew there they flew there they're
paying all the money the people came to
see that's a great point they they came
to see what you're gonna do you're gonna
give the best spot of the night to the
local middle guy 100 who does 25 minutes
God bless you I love I love feature ax I
know it's a feature not a middle you're
welcome Rich boss right but they you get
the best spot so the guy goes up warms
them up for 10-15 minutes then you're
gonna give that guy the Primo [ __ ]
spot you're not selling merch
I hate that they're not too drunk
they're focused they're ready to laugh
and you're gonna put him up for 25
minutes right and then bring me up at
the end right and you're right when I'm
gone up 15 minutes before the movie's
gonna end everything builds up I got
them you're gonna send a [ __ ] team a
horde of waitresses that could give a
[ __ ] about me yeah or stand up they're
just trying to get to a cigarette or a
joint or a drink somewhere they want the
[ __ ] out which I understand it's a [ __ ]
God bless them all because it's a [ __ ]
up job to do they're gonna just good
ones are like on another level like if
you're a quiet wait staff like we
[ __ ] notice it and we appreciate it
100 that's a tough gig I had a girl give
me the finger at CB live she walked
first of all she walks out in the front
okay now you said it here I'm texting
Brandon I'm telling him
I'm telling him walks out in the front I
got a video of it I got the video yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna bring up the video
and you can send it to yourself yeah
um
[Music]
I'm gonna give him my phone
because I don't want to go what is it
third Brandon 765 can you also send it
to me so I can send it to the club yeah
all right but this is my question with
the check spot that I don't understand
you have one show on a Saturday night
yes the next show is an hour later half
an hour later what the [ __ ] are they
dropping the checks in the middle of
your [ __ ] for like they don't have
anything else after the seller doesn't
do it and you guys have like 10 shows
seriously I know there's no point I
don't understand the logic of it I asked
the a club owner because I said hey can
we do no check spots he goes what do you
want what do you want this week I'm a
big fan we sold some tickets what do you
want I got no checks buddy because we
can't do that he's like we'll give you
champagne in The Green Room whatever
I'll tell you why yeah he goes a we
don't have a bouncer here so people
could just run out I'm like nobody's
gonna run out secondly he goes it [ __ ]
over the wait staff because we don't tip
less after which I'm like that's
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] and then at the
end he goes we just don't want to do it
we know how to do it this way
there drop it to you let me okay it's
all about they just used to doing in a
certain way they don't want to change
that's it that's all it is it's laziness
too also hire a [ __ ] bouncer well
that too are you kidding me you don't
wanna just put the [ __ ] bartender
here's how you solve the [ __ ] you
need to answer the comedy here's how you
you do you do but here's how you solve
the problem ready you take the uh the
host he goes up and does 10. then you
take the feature God bless you
go up and do 20. you do 20 and then I go
up and I do my time I do an hour as a
headliner I believe you should be doing
an hour yeah you do 45 minutes
okay God bless you I understand once in
a while but if you're doing 35 40 you're
not a headline right right okay but go
up and do your hour and then have the MC
go back up and do 10 more minutes number
one it gives him it makes him a better
comic he's gonna go up do all your dumb
ads they already know who he is he's the
host he's the guy let him go up [ __ ]
with the people hey you had a good time
how about that thing blah blah blah make
sure you tip it away let him go up you
it's it's you're adding so the time that
they're still paying the checks that I'm
not up there they're still just getting
entertained you're dropping all your
[ __ ] instead of instead of letting
them know that a better Comics coming
next week right in front of me right
right hey guys Damon Wayans coming next
week oh good yeah but why don't you just
give them their receipts now so they can
have them do it that way they're they're
[ __ ] these clubs they don't want to
change that's it they don't want to
[ __ ] change they're still like an
Applebee's they just [ __ ] churn out
riblets and this and this is how we do
it and [ __ ] them I'm done with the the
checks
I love all the waitresses God bless them
sure
I'm not a [ __ ] monkey
you know this girl is funny though she
did give me the finger and it was kind
of funny do we have it it made me laugh
I can't wait on this video but here's
what's the finger didn't bother but the
finger made me laugh actually it really
did kind of arouse me watch this
confidence she's in the not even a duck
the chick the blind what's this from how
long ago this is a week two weeks ago
the blonde yeah it is look at the worst
it's the worst you know to bend down she
don't give a [ __ ] I mean stop pause that
for a second he's having a blast doing
this that look at she walked in front of
everybody yeah and stood there like not
even quickly right you know what I mean
and I'm just like wow go ahead
sorry he's not sneaky at all she's like
[ __ ] you fat boy keep going
boom go [ __ ] yourself this is a problem
with my show and he scares me to the
finger yeah on her side you [ __ ]
dirty Americans that's why this
country's [ __ ]
you see a vagina let's get behind it
[Applause]
where is this Phoenix oh nice well the
problem is a lot of people hire people
who want to be common and so that to her
that was like her moment I mean look she
I don't I don't she made it funny and
all that it's not I don't give a [ __ ]
about that and it would it relieved the
pressure of it she was actually pretty
cool but when you when you don't teach
your staff to even duck down sir from
behind from behind you don't walk out
you're literally taking them do you
understand what a joke works I know I
gotta [ __ ] get them into the story
the setup and they're going wait who had
the my time yeah wait you only put two
dot that's comedy poison unbelievable no
other [ __ ] thing did they do this in
by the way and here's the nail on the
call yeah they don't do that in Hamilton
you know here's a nail in the coffin I
did a show I did a gig once I did an
album there at this club not gonna say
the club
say it
[Laughter]
this is your first album yeah first
album and second album so then they go
all right since you're doing a taping we
won't do checks we'll do them after so
they can do it that's the worst part is
you basically told me you can do it and
you don't do it don't tell me you can't
do it if the comedy seller does it the
seller 17 shows a night oh my God sold
out I think the special the seller they
didn't serve drink drinks everyone
ordered drinks at the beginning two
drinks everyone orders drinks at the
beginning so there wouldn't be wait
Staffing they're [ __ ] smart and they
know the show is the most important part
if you distract these people at all it's
gonna [ __ ] up the show of course if you
if you let them watch the movie they'll
enjoy it yeah you know what's great for
comedy reminding yourself of your
finances yeah that's what I want to
think about right now oh having some
have [ __ ] uh uh a phoenix seven walk
in the front row well you're with your a
phoenix two wife
can you imagine you would Avatar too
someone comes in who got the mai tai
screwdriver exactly old-fashioned we
didn't leave tip on it so if you want to
leave good shut up what uh do you have
other peeves other things that are
bothering you either you yeah I got I
got a real hey
that's a good idea beef
and why is he a piece you my pet peeve I
just want to go off
do it hoops come on
Bobby ice what do I do I want to get you
I don't understand what I want to get
you a little backpack and one of those
boom boxes with the hoops today
I don't understand what I did I don't
understand Phil Hanley next
Sam I'm telling you Bobby this is
literally every day of my [ __ ] life
Liz you mad Liz you mad Liz you mad Liz
please
he texts me PLS which also [ __ ]
infuriates just [ __ ] right please
[ __ ] right please please you mad
you mad why are you mad why do you have
Angry shoes you mad you're my [ __ ]
anger issue [ __ ] like every
[ __ ] every day ever he's needy Sam's
really really easy okay as well you
don't say okay you're right K come on
man give me another you have an iPhone
[Laughter]
she's an espresso martini drink I do
like the espresso for laser was either
aperol Spritz dirty martini or espresso
Martini I wish it was the espresso
martini and Arturo Arturo's Coal Oven
Pizza Delicious great spot right you'd
have been there have you been there I've
never been wow oh I should say this I've
never been invited oh you were on the
road my pet peeve you were interested
next week it'll be it'll be killer I
always get invited to you guys sneak
away at night too it bugs me we do yeah
you and [ __ ] Liz and [ __ ] Finn
Phil
[Laughter]
sneak away where's Liz I don't know
she's gone and you guys are at some
[ __ ] trendy spot sucking down
something sticking something in your
face yeah Phil's talking about his dumb
set or some watch he got and you're
pretending to be interested and pretend
to be his friend I don't be interested
in the watch I've never pretended to be
I'm not interested in watches at all
yeah do you know if Phil dies I get two
of his Rolexes which one Phil dies he
told me I can't remember because it
means nothing to me but I guess I'll
kill him if you give me one
all right because I have no idea which
one told me the Thunder whatever the
[ __ ] it is are you a watch Person yeah
yeah
that's beautiful Liz Liz Liz and Phil
actually came with me to get them yeah
you're just trashing this stuff what am
I gonna I'm trying to be funny
how much I love the guy
I'm not a big watch I also a huge watch
guys
that's a great one but I'm worried I I
think like walking around with a Rolex
you're like a [ __ ] Mark well you're a
marker you don't know what the [ __ ] you
do Phil Hanley is what I mean Mark yeah
once again he'll bore somebody to death
though
we should jump him in a ski mask
I didn't give it back to him
he's like I should bogey
no we if we if we Corner fail and we're
just like give me just to watch I don't
care about your phone just your watch
he's like ah let me do the talking your
voice is not threatening I know you
sound like a kid trying to be really
good to watch
right
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
button now I've bought comedians thank
you who have you bought
the guy in the closet case
um I I bought I bought specials anytime
it comes out I just bought a Gillian
keeves oh yeah I gotta buy that I bought
that so good I buy it I watch it on the
road or the plane just to support yeah I
mean you gotta so you can still watch
Comedy a lot of people a lot of comics
are like I can't watch anything comedy I
I actually was becoming I think uh maybe
six years ago that bitter old [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are they but now that I
watch Comics I I like comedy again I
actually guys I watch comics and I'm
like wow it's fun like um
um what's his name Mateo okay [ __ ]
man dude he makes me his jokes are
[ __ ] he's so good yeah and it's funny
because I remember him when he first
came in it was all right you know what I
mean so that's why I was kind of like
what the [ __ ] these young guys coming up
even you guys I watch your stuff and I'm
like this is a [ __ ] great joke like I
laugh out loud I try to comment on it
too but I enjoy you notice right like
how people get funnier it's it's wild
it's crazy right because yeah you guys
all got funnier uh Joe list oh he's a
beast is so funny right night and day
[ __ ] it's like yeah before it takes time
you know it's like you find yourself you
get comfortable I mean it's a process
but it's like I came out like when I
first saw you guys I was here doing my
thing and then I was like yeah and then
I came out of it and all of a sudden I'm
looking at your comedy on Instagram like
the bits and I'm like that's [ __ ]
great so it's a weird feeling for me to
be to see the I never I didn't see the
transition it just happened yeah the
time right so now you guys are all
killers right it sometimes feels like
like even I mean I see these idiots
every [ __ ] day and it feels like
all of a sudden today I'll be like oh
[ __ ] like when the [ __ ] did this person
get funny yeah no it's it's like all of
a sudden they have the penny drops and
you're like what the [ __ ] you gotta
figure it out that's why I'm so it's so
to come back to I got to come back to
The Cellar
gotta come back but I'm nervous about
Spots
I'm so good to be around that energy
that kind of like energy like I just see
people you're like even when you're not
on stage being around comedians when I I
was out in I did the Rogan that he was
like I'm doing the Vulcan tonight you
want to go on I was like yeah but I was
so nervous because I haven't really done
spots and they had all these Young Bucks
in front of me and they're going up and
they murdered they're great for
hilarious and then I went up and I was
like
you know that that thing yeah well you
know when you go to The Cellar and
Norton's on or someone's on and they're
crushing and and like what do you want
to say you're like and then they're like
you guys you gotta you know slide on the
stage you're up there and you're like
[ __ ] it you can touch the ceiling and
and then you get well as soon as you get
that laugh you're good but I I on the on
that stage with them I I was killing and
I was like oh my God it's like it takes
over yeah yeah and then I was off and I
was so jacked I gotta I gotta go back
yeah
it's good it's a good skill set to have
like you kind of get too caught up in
the hour structure because you're
writing a new hour and the bits get
longer and it becomes harder and harder
to do 15 but it's it's a necessary skill
it's like auditioning to acting to
getting the gig to to booking the gig
auditioning is a way different animal
than actually acting when you get the
gig it's a whole different thing you got
to do right but when you audition for it
you got to go in that room you gotta
look you gotta know look around look at
the people in the eyes you have to to
kind of absorb their energy take away
their power kind of absorb it and be
like oh this is my time right now and
who am I I'm working with you hey what's
up I'm Rob what's your name great uh I'm
gonna do this okay I'm gonna over here
where's the camera take over yeah it's
like a whole thing you have to do and
then when you're ready go I'm ready can
we start great you know do your thing
and then do it and then just you and
that person until you're done and then
you go great that's it like if you don't
do that if you walk in and that's the
way spots yeah like it's so much
pressure and it means nothing only to
you right no one else well it's like it
sucks when you're doing a set and you
just see someone you respect walk in the
room ah [ __ ] I'm working on [ __ ] dude I
hate when Comics come in and watch when
I'm doing new jokes that feels like when
Comics watch the most how about when
they when they leave
near a walk out what what I almost said
something I went Bob
I had Ricky Gervais I bombed in front of
Louie and Ricky oh
oh they were laughing body bombs are the
best Bobby bombs are the best bombs
there's nothing better than seeing link
when she knows she has some sick sense
when I'm gonna bomb yeah she'll stand
under the light which is right at the
Village there's one light so if you look
over you'll just see her like this
waiting waiting and just watching you
just eat your own [ __ ] for like 15. and
I get energy so I'm like
and there's nothing I would dude I was I
was uh I was in the uh I was [ __ ] it was
after your bachelor party when we did
the episode we got shit-faced yeah to
the wedding yeah it's gonna be awesome
we'd love to have you oh I'm sorry I
didn't I didn't get a [ __ ] I said it
to Phil that's his worst [ __ ] did you do
Rogan no not yet so we do it we do we do
Norman's uh we do get wasted on the
episode here we go to a Old Homestead we
get oh yeah we get drunker there then
Mark and I end up at the cellar I'm on
stage struggling to get through the set
and I just see Liz and Rachel Feinstein
in the doorway oh my God the entire set
they're doing this
I'm trying to keep a straight face like
I'm struggling enough just to enunciate
words
I got a huge laugh and I just looked and
I go
[Laughter]
that was the worst we were
why did De Niro walk out oh dude I just
have no Charisma like I don't have it
you know what I mean like is that the
number one guy that like it like that's
like who else would hurt that much
walking out I don't know it hurts that's
like top of the [ __ ] yeah that's
happened to me a bunch of times though I
mean the Conan O'Brien people were doing
a uh uh showcase yeah uh I stand up New
York and as soon as I went on they
walked out wow I fell to the floor what
I just started talking to the ceiling I
was just like I've worked all week on
this set as they're walking out because
they told me that I might get a chance
to get on Conan O'Brien and as I'm on
this is I go God you hate me and I hate
you God I hate you back I was just
talking to God and they were like that's
Jessica's [ __ ] what are you doing
yeah dude it's happened but DeNiro was
bad he came in to see people for that
movie oh the movie yeah with Kirsten and
um he came in and he was watching
Everybody wow and then and they go hey
give it up for Robert Kelly and somebody
I just all of a sudden I saw a couple
seconds maybe 30 40 maybe a minute or so
hey what's going on blah and
you just I just I had nothing that
caught his eye
well if it helps the movie sucked I just
came here the greatest
damn hello
yeah I got none of that that's what I
thought I was gonna get Cape Fear dinero
right no I didn't I got the one way he
was [ __ ] in the chair with Robert
Awakenings
I think a great guy but I also read like
dude I've read he was such a dick to
Sybil Shepard on Taxi Driver like such a
[ __ ] dick De Niro really Oh I thought
he was probably I was thinking of the
show taxi
famously well he only likes black women
to be honest well I think he just didn't
think she could act oh wow yeah
yeah he well dude it's funny that he's a
huge Tim Norton fan I know
Norton fan and that's from that movie
but he was Bobby he was so sweet he was
like the nicest was he really I heard he
was very bad he was really he wanted I
I'm blaming myself I'm blaming the lack
of it don't blame don't blame yourself
honey if I walk if you walk on stage if
you're there is De Niro looking for
comedians for a movie about comedy and a
guy gets on stage with me hey what's up
blah blah and it does nothing for your
palette like it you literally go you
ready yeah I'm ready and you walk out
you don't got it
[Laughter]
but yeah DeRosa was here not bragging
but we had him on and he was he was
saying like I don't do spots in the city
it's worthless I go on the road
I don't know what I said it's not that
he doesn't do spray he can't he can't
get spots well yeah yeah I think he said
that yeah he has liver spots at this
point he's like I've been 8 15 with a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich right
and uh yeah 10 25 with a turkey club
yeah I'd rather be here than slinging
sandwiches you can't find it I guess
what is on Netflix it's Norton's uh
yeah I heard that movie was terrible
though maybe he could have watched a
little more Bobby it's never too early
to play holiday music and it's never too
early to start thinking about gifts
whether it's just for a friend or the
friends of your pants
it's your penis in your balls you can
make this season to be jolly with
manscaped their Platinum package has it
all the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and
weed whacker nose and hair ear hair
trimmer
now the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and
the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer they feature proprietary
Advanced Skin safe technology to protect
your delicate parts and your holes both
are waterproof so you can shave in the
shower sounds classy to me don't forget
to apply to the for their aluminum-free
Ultra Premium deodorant for that cologne
quality scent on the go manscaped is
even thrown in two free gifts the
manscape boxers and the shed travel bag
the Platinum package 4.0 covers all your
bases from head to toe tell them how to
do it Mark here's what you got to do get
20 off and free shipping with code drunk
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
drunk manscape get your jingle balls
ready for the holidays
hey folks when you want a smooth high
that you know was made right here in the
U.S of a look no further an ounce of
Hope based out of Memphis Tennessee uh
ounce of Hope is your One-Stop shop for
Delta eight Delta 9 and CBD Edibles oils
and more I use this stuff every night
literally to go to sleep I love it it's
not too high you don't want to go into
some edible coma where you can't see
straight you don't know when you're
gonna die and you're panicking anytime
the phone rings this stuff is just the
right amount it's just perfect it helps
me sleep better harnessing the power of
aquaponics
ounce of Hope is the farm to table brand
for getting high aquaponics combines
fish and plant farming so all the
nutrients released by The Fish make an
extremely healthy plan ah you're getting
high thanks to fish [ __ ] visit
ounceofhope.com and use drunk for 20 off
your first order that's o u n c e o f h
o p e.com with promo code drunk and
start saving on the best Delta 8 and
Delta 9 products here it is
get on it
God Bless America and God bless sheath
underwear let's show Mark we're both
wearing them right now look at that yeah
sheath underwear keeps your balls off
your leg which I mean I love that little
pouch right there oh yeah the idea for
sheath came from its founder US Army
soldier Robert pattender in his second
tour in Iraq this guy is a [ __ ]
veteran dude oh yeah it worked for him
it's gonna work for you I wear sheath
underwear and they're great I wear them
all it's like my favorite you have your
favorite pairs in the drawer yep I have
a few crappy swiss cheese undies and
then I got my sheath ones that don't
break down they're good support the show
support this awesome veteran-owned
Company Mark tell them how to do it go
to sheathunderwear.com use promo code
drunk to get 20 off your first order
every order comes with cheese 100 money
back guarantee that's
sheathunderwear.com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your balls
hey folks we might be drunk is brought
to you by rocket money most Americans
think they spend about eighty dollars a
month on subscriptions when the actual
total cost is closer to 200 clams
you could be wasting a hundred dollars
each month on subscriptions you don't
even know about that's why we love
rocket money formerly known as true bill
the app shows all your subscriptions in
one place and cancels whatever ones you
don't want rocket money can even find
subscriptions you didn't know you were
paying for wow
you may even find out you've been double
charge for a subscription holy hell
they're raping you to cancel a
subscription just press cancel and
Rocket money will take care of the rest
easy peasy get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to rocketmoney.com drunk
seriously you could save hundreds per
year that's
rocketmoney.com
drunkard cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com
slash drunk get on it
I'm not good with famous people dude I'm
just not good I'm not really either oh
you have the Jerry the famous Jerry oh
my God that's a great story get your
hands off
yeah
that was that a Rolex I can't have
another drink um
Everybody heard that story no not on
here it's the best all right I'm gonna
give you all right ever you have to go
buy my special right now there you go
I'm not special right now and he's doing
and it's the Louis ck.com Lewis Lewis
yeah don't do Louie don't do Louie there
it is there it is
yeah anymore what the [ __ ] but you're in
that movie too and scroll down you're
amazing in that movie where am I
jeez oh my God Berry text
everybody
I love that I love that you're under his
special sorry
under his next special I [ __ ] up I
mean what's going on text you're texting
right yeah I'm calling oh get him on
speaker yeah this is Leah we love Leo
though we love Leah hey Leah you're live
on uh Mark Mark podcast
I'm promoting uh kill box uh that you
are a producer on Executive yeah we're
promoting it but I sent them to we're
sending them to Lewis ck.com but we
can't seem to find where it is on it was
at the top and we don't know where it is
at Louis ck.com
and one second
um
who is ck.com and then I think it is
it's at the bottom
where it says shows and specials oh my
I'm not at the top homepage
I mean
I still got big I got two weeks of
promoting this special left we're in the
money we paid we're this is profit time
Leah and you got that that movie July I
mean that's over you're in Fourth of
July though it did it I'm in fourth is
live but look at I ain't getting any
money out of that listen me and Leo
trying to make some cash 4th of July I
mean good movie [ __ ] your list [ __ ] your
list that's a rip
that's a great movie I Didn't Know
Fourth of July is a great movie yeah
it's a great movie get that you can get
Louis special but go I mean we gotta
have it no it's a whole series
all right
[Music]
all right
shows go to shows and specials okay here
we go all right we're gonna have it
right up this is great podcast
tell the Jerry Seinfeld Story please all
right listen so I Jack this is this is
why and Colin Quinn if somebody famous
comes in will take me out of the
building he will say Bobby it's time to
go home in the middle of hanging out Ray
Romano is it anybody famous comes in
Colin will go Bobby it's time to go I'm
having fun it goes Bob we need to go and
he'll take me outside and go because no
he knows now he's good like that I'm bad
with famous people oh okay so Jerry's
coming down with the um crew the film
comedian comedian this is you know you
remember Jerry used to hang out a little
bit yeah yeah so I'm scared to text him
I'm like you know how to save it uh be
your friend uh he he uh
he he's filming all this stuff Jerry
Simon I mean he's the biggest comic in
the world he's filming this thing the
camera's everywhere I don't want
anything to do with it I don't want to
be that guy if in my head this these are
thoughts I had I'm letting you in on the
inside I don't want if we become friends
to happen organically I don't want to be
I don't want to be in this if he wanted
me in this he'll have me in it I don't
want to you know beg to be in it'll kind
of suck up to be in it I'm gonna you
know what I mean yeah because there's
Comics there that are just sitting at
the table trying to have a convo to get
in the [ __ ] movie I stay away I don't
even say nothing to him while he's
filming it to respect his you know fame
or whatever so one night I'm sitting
there was talking about the Rangers and
we'll talk about the year Gretzky one
did he was he there the one the year
they won the Stanley Cup I'm saying yes
I don't know they're saying no big bet
going on doll I'll take a dollar he goes
I'll take some of that action right
there organic Jerry 20 million dollars
right and a car his PR his the
producer's the camera guy I'll take all
right so we have this organic connection
Michael broke the ice we all right boom
you're in you're in Jerry's in bang so
not gonna go away I gotta do a gig I
have to fly into Buffalo it's an
afternoon gig hmm I have to hire my own
they won't pick me up
I have to hire my own guy so I hire a
guy shows up in a minivan with Captain's
chairs oh yeah okay I get in there's a
VCR with headphones he's got headphones
every episode of Seinfeld Hmm this is
that weekend
so he goes I love Jerry seinfa well I
watch him all day long I pick people up
he's all like whipped up he goes yeah
put it on we'll watch it it's a sign so
we're watching Seinfeld episodes I'm in
this thing in the back of a van uh like
you know those 80s love fans oh no you
got your old duct taped in the trunk all
right I love Seinfeld
so we go to the he takes me I take him
to lunch because I I the show's at three
o'clock you take the minivan guy I gotta
go to lunch so he comes with me we're
there he's calling me Jerry the whole
time say I love it Jerry I'm Bobby he's
like I know but I just love Jerry I'm
like okay
Kathy Bates and misery yeah right we
don't even have time so the gig I don't
know this gig it's it's a college thing
it's outside it's a beer fest outside
bad news after a metal band the Buffalo
which keeps getting worse in Buffalo on
and off rain showers next to a skydiving
simulator so every five minutes a day
jet engine will go off
a college student drunk will be just
flying next to me so the the band gets
off I get up there it's hell it starts
raining they go you know 50 yards back
under another tent it stops they come
back out I'm [ __ ] working it I'm like
boom I get him I lose them the [ __ ]
jet goes off guy comes by funnel they're
[ __ ] wasted the sun's out yeah it's
so bad I I hit 45 minutes contractually
thank you good night I'm like but the
guy grabs me like The A Team takes me
through mud throws me in the back of the
van I got like maybe an hour and 10
minutes to make my plane goes all the
way as we're driving I'm going to get
you there don't worry about it Jerry I'm
like it's Bob
we get to the airport I make it to the
plane he goes can you just do me a favor
can you get me a sign autograph of Jerry
I go listen dude I met him the other
night it might happen I can ask oh my
god oh you can't say that I got that I
got the best story in the world right
this hell gig this is up his alley yes
right so I go back to the seller the
next night I'm on I'm on right after
Jerry what so I walk downstairs the
hallway's packed with people watching
Jerry of course the camera Crews there
he's on stage this is 2002 by the way
he's the biggest he's been the biggest
he's ever been he walks off stage
organically we're friends he walks off
and I go hey dude you won Gretzky wasn't
on and I had the buck and he took he
looked at me like like who the [ __ ] oh
yeah and he took the bus
and then he walks up two steps I go hey
dude but I got a great story for you
first oh no he goes you you want your
buck back
and I was like oh no whatever it takes
another two steps she turns around and
goes Hey listen
I'm gonna be up to the table uh having
food as soon as you're done come up
we'll talk we'll have some food and
we'll we'll uh we'll talk stuff out and
I was like dude I got a great story for
you man I went to Buffalo you're gonna
love this story I can't wait to tell you
it he goes not you oh he was talking
about he was talking to the lady next to
me
[Music]
she just looked at me she goes sorry and
he just walked away never to talk to me
again I
[Music]
don't
know
that's worse than if he stuffed the
dollar bill in your mouth and kicked you
down the stairs yeah not you is more
painful just as you know Jerry not you
and then he walked away and a crowd of
people around me too it just went you
saw the comics who were there oh dude it
was like somebody like was it Norton
somebody got caught like [ __ ]
somebody in the ass like that type of
Silence like ah
you guys that's a bad song [ __ ] her
in the ass dude
it was bad it was so bad that's amazing
but that's my company name now not you
Inc oh that's amazing it's like the
n-word you spin it
how do you how do you spin did they put
it back up top uh no absolutely not
let's see now
[Applause]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] texture and tell her she's a
[ __ ] Champion she's a [ __ ]
Champion Louie's on a podcast promoting
his special right now and he's like
where the [ __ ] is it I don't know good
for her man
[Music]
I love being at work tonight I'll see
you later thanks for putting it up
two more weeks baby two more weeks two
more weeks two more weeks
yeah thank you so much you guys too dude
I'm I tell you what the best part about
promoting this special was for me is
getting to do everybody's podcast and
the and not to be [ __ ] but uh bring It
Up the Love of the
let me let me limited hey not to be a
silly [ __ ] there we go
that's the name of my production company
not to be a [ __ ] homosexual
[Applause]
not to be an emotional uh [ __ ] yeah
or to
um you know uh sappy but the love of the
comics all the comics podcasts the fact
that we don't have to do we don't have
to go to people and get a yes from
people I don't even know right and who
you know who might not be fans that we
can just do this yep and we can sell our
albums put our stuff out we don't have
to ask permission anymore because we're
just taking care of each other yeah and
getting our fans to like skank Fest
Rogue and you guys all the podcasts I
did
promoted me more than any show I could
ever went on yeah or anything I could
well these late night shows they're such
a [ __ ] to get on and then there's like
you didn't even move the needle I know
and you made me a million people kill my
joke yeah you gotta jump through hoops
it's so yeah it's great and it's the
comic Love is Real because we are a
family and we and not to be Savvy as
well but like you know not to be a
homosexual as well but uh
no we we it is a family and that's why
like we talk about Steve earlier in the
episode we love them and like if you if
you've been to the cellar this is the
dude who let you in this is the best the
best guy the best we all loved him like
you you should have seen the scene there
we were there the night after it
happened and it was like dude there were
flowers in this seat he sat and that
people from the neighborhood were
dropping I mean literally literally like
people from the neighborhood people walk
by and we're like hey yeah we've heard
everyone from the Blue Note came over
one at a time last night yeah he was the
nicest guy because every time I was
there he he you come out you go away for
a while you come back and there's a new
person at the door right it's like
excuse me it's like what yeah [ __ ]
what are you out of your mind you know
what I mean but 22 years every time 22
years ago and he goes not you
uh but Steve was just you know he would
talk to you yeah it wasn't a yo what's
up it was hey man how you doing Bobby
right yeah man how's your wife how's
your son how's that [ __ ] this piece
of [ __ ] had him saying hey Liz you mad
you were filming it because he would go
up to her and he'd make sure I was an
earshot so I could enjoy it and he would
go Liz can I ask you something she'd be
like oh yeah and you go are you mad and
she's like ah
dude my parents I texted my parents and
they were like he took such good games
my parents said the same thing he would
like literally when my parents were
there he would like recognize their
family and I think Lewis Gomez said it
the best when I showed up at the cell he
didn't ask me who I was yeah whatever
which is huge yeah that's a first that's
crazy yeah that's like wow that's crazy
yeah but Lewis uh told me that shout out
to Lewis for the skank Fest you're doing
great things but he said a guy a big
Corporation tried to buy it and he said
nah because it'll ruin it you can't you
can't well they're starting to show up
oh really what I said those industry
came this year I told you I'm like you
can't let them don't let them in dance
they're gonna ruin it they're gonna be
on there no way Louis is gonna let a
legitimate company with legitimate
lawyers and accountants show up ATT uh
how's he gonna afford his Lexus
there's no way he's letting them know
God bless him because he built it I mean
it's really important it's for the fans
and and uh and it's not just Lewis it's
Jay and and Dave and Christine yeah
let me tell you some of that staff
they're [ __ ] they're so good yeah
they're on it they're so good because
they know who you are they know what you
mean to the festival yeah and they treat
you I can't tell you I was like I need a
chair we got a chair for you Mr Kelly
this is a guy who's probably a comic but
he's he you know and he's there's no ego
involved they're like look man we're
glad to be here too and they work all
day all night for four days five days
straight longer than that like setting
up all that [ __ ] like there's looking at
it walking in there's so much that goes
into that they're working for months and
then on it's going to be bigger and
bigger and bigger oh yeah yeah it was so
much fun and it's all based on [ __ ]
atrocious evil [ __ ] up hilarious
comedy it's it's it's not bending one
second I walked in on whatever Saturday
yeah there's no thing at skank that's
another thing I walked in on yeah
boxing match where it was four Dudes
with shock shock collars blindfolded
kicking the [ __ ] out of each other yeah
it was amazing we look it I'm not I'm
not gonna trash uh meaningful comedy I
think that's what I call it sure God
bless you meaningful meaningful comedy
opposite of Comedy but it's like
important people want
when everyone's trying to make a point
yeah what makes you laugh harder than
just pure silliness when every late
night host was like Trump this Conan
would just go out and do jokes yes and
there was something kind of beautiful
about that and if you're all doing Trump
it's go it's over it's rude it's not
edgy no no I was next to Luis Gomez he
lost a bet with Jay we're in front of
thousands of people on live streaming on
moments and they stuck a Nintendo on men
duck hunter gun in his bum I held the
mic to his mouth play the music the the
sound effect for the duck hunt and it
was I mean dude dude Jake Shields a
champion and he's fighting
[Laughter]
Girl Comics everybody was on stage they
raffled off two stage seats for guys to
watch it at fifteen hundred dollars a
pop and G big J stuck a gun in Lewis's
butt yeah and it was the greatest one of
the greatest things I've ever seen I
love it it was so funny outrageous and
stupid it made no sense and I think
comedy all kinds of Comedy should exist
like you say the beautiful comedy that's
great that exists yeah but you need if
you have that you need the other end but
no one's trying to take away meaningful
comedy that's what was feels weird about
this like you're like hey we gotta shut
that down it's racist if you do a
meaningful comedy to me you better
[ __ ] take it on the road and focus
test it a little laughs yeah you bet
because when you're just you don't make
it comedy you don't have to you should
do that but they don't have to you don't
have to but you should because it'll
make it better it'll make it tighter and
it can still be have meaning and be
tight and honed and go good there's
something about not being famous that
makes you funnier because you're in a
room full of people that like you and
then there's a bunch of people that
don't know who the [ __ ] you are and you
have to get them yes so when you're at a
club and you have to get 25 of the room
who just came because they got tickets
or whatever yeah that makes you have to
you know what I mean when you show up
and they're all there to see you which
is awesome sure greatest feeling the
goal but you you get away with a lot
more yeah but on the other end of that
when no one knows who you are you have
to kill every time and you can't write
new [ __ ] absolutely that's definitely
the middle yeah I think you're right
there's a there's a middle ground in
that but it does make you better but
these the the meaningful comedy which I
dude I don't hate you know what I mean
it's good it's good yeah Gary gallman's
uh depressed
brilliant writer Gary is is but that's
special yeah
Gary so much I because I know I love him
and the fact that he went away to get
healthy first and then came back and was
a comic second you know what I mean like
those are brilliantly written jokes if
you haven't seen it the Great Depression
HBO Game yeah Louis ck.com
I met you guys for the first time
together in Atlanta like it must have
been like 2010 or something yeah and you
were both I was a [ __ ] young ass
comic and you guys were both so cool to
me and was like you know that was a
mistake
yeah you [ __ ] up are you mad
[Laughter]
I'm a little upset I saw it I saw
Gaffigan downstairs at a comedy club and
Legion skanks were upstairs doing their
crazy horse [ __ ] and Gavin's like man
thank God for them and I'm like what
he's the cleanest comic on the planet
I'm like you like them he's like they
keep the they keep moving the line
otherwise other people just move it all
the way that way without them yeah you
need both sides yeah to keep moving you
need a dice you need again you need a
prior you needed this [ __ ] right
you need those guys to push the
boundaries as far as they can push it
and then we have so much room to play in
right so much more people can exist yeah
yeah that's a good point I mean even
though if he was around today he'd be a
corporate shell
there's no way he'd be around today
unless you got that surgery speaking of
the look at this [ __ ] have you seen this
the Richard Pryor singing that's been
going around oh God it's amazing you
guys a good voice why did but can I
could before you play it before this
ruins everything that's what I say it's
weird I get it he's a good singer but
why does every comic when they make it a
lot of them have think they can put out
us this is before we made it no yeah
yeah yeah
1966. he hadn't made it yet
[Music]
I can't please stop are you gonna cry no
Bobby's gonna cry
is this literally is ruining prior for
me all right close that's how I feel
it's great that sweater I love it
singing ruins them for you but him
Freebase and enlightened himself on fire
is good that helps that helps brings him
up yeah I mean if you saw Bert Kreischer
singing like that you'd be like that's
the most insane thing I've ever seen in
my life
dude what do you talk about he grew up
in a whorehouse what that's how he made
his money when he was 10. yeah [ __ ]
walk around baby Go sing for the general
he is Don Draper he's basically the Don
Draper of Comedy this tragic [ __ ]
life oh yeah yeah and oh no no no no no
no no no I'm gonna throw up
oh wow
all right now
that's a lot that's a real milker
yikes
any other any other peeves or wrecks
anyone I mean you can't really top the
ones I mean I have pet pee I I just have
people who break the law but not just
not the law of the land uh human law we
have a lot like
Halloween
this is the first year that our
neighborhood had we got kids in the last
few years we our neighborhood dies
neighborhood I don't even knows but
neighborhood will die uh families move
in the 50s they have kids the
neighborhood's popping those people get
old the kids move away the neighborhood
dies those people die new families move
in then they have kids the kids get
older they play on the Block it's
rejuvenate that's what happened to my
neighborhood my street
never did trick-or-treat on my street
because there was no kids all old people
now there's kids so we did
trick-or-treat we had a party and uh we
did we walked around the neighborhood we
sent the Flyers hey number one if you
have a pumpkin if you have lights or any
decorations for Halloween and you don't
have candy or you're not answering your
door you're announced you should be
slapped in the face yeah you're right
you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
interesting if you lit your house up
orange and had a pumpkin a hologram
pumpkin on your [ __ ] side of your
house and my kids ring your dog and you
and I can see your TV your 100 foot
Plasma on the wall watching the [ __ ]
stupid Sports and you don't answer the
door I should be able to crawl in your
window and slap you in your [ __ ] face
and then take your remote and throw it I
just have a picture of Bobby like
banging on someone's door screaming you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
with these kids behind you what the [ __ ]
is the candy I do it from the street I'm
going I I just kept going we see you
we see you and now here's another one
hello
[Laughter]
that was impressive
that's what's going on what candy are
you giving out at your home dude we gave
out everything full size or a fun size
no you can't do full size that's too
much you can't it's too much it's too
full size was like a 80s thing 90s
killed Ralphie man yeah yeah
you got to give but I let him take as
much as they want that's what I said
take as much as you want now now let's
not get carried away if the little
streety [ __ ] goes he's like I meant
three yeah as much as you want is three
to four right you go five six I'm
slapping your hand I'm looking at your
dad going this way you raised this piece
of [ __ ] right but here's another thing
too
that's what happened with the bowl on
the uh I'm telling you what these
because these Savages yeah they take all
of the bowl they took the ball it never
was this is my gateway to juvenile hall
right here oh that's why communism
doesn't work why do you leave I murdered
somebody yeah I raped the girl it
happened what did you do I stole a bowl
of candy in White Plains we started with
a box of Whoppers yeah it ended with a
knife yeah the guy was in there I saw
him live but he didn't come out so I
took the whole Bowl my ring camera went
off probably no joke 15 times Halloween
night all of it and I took some
screenshots all of it hey take one not
the whole Bowl I'm not kidding this is a
thing now these scumbags these piece of
garbage kids who don't have [ __ ]
morals because their families suck
are just going up taking there's a ball
first of all I blame you you lazy
[ __ ] if you're in there open the
door open the door no I'm playing with
the person between these two okay you
got the resident the resident next door
yeah if you're in the house open the
[ __ ] door get a mask do something and
say hey how you doing participate teach
these for your job as a candy dispenser
on Halloween is to teach these little
kids one [ __ ] face one and then they
know they go to the next house one one
you hit one one one one one you know to
take one but all these lazy [ __ ]
Halloween couple Millennial [ __ ] people
who left New York to go to [ __ ]
Westchester and get a house like you
Bobby I know I know but I have I have
morals
I don't have a dad but I have good
morals you do you do yeah not you but
you raise it they take the they not only
do they this is why these kids suck they
take all the candy and they have a bag
to put in but they take the bowls no
literally The Whole Bowl the physical
bowl and some of these people are using
these great bowls these nice rolls that
they like which is that's not smart on
their part though but why why can't you
leave a bowl out you should be able to
but I don't I still don't think it's
something 53 you could leave a bowl out
I don't think 1980s leave a ball out 70s
leave a ball dude in the 80s when I went
trick-or-treating first of all two uh uh
pillowcases I would go out by myself
yeah and we were not klansman
that was my outfit I needed one for the
outfit yeah and to get into the club
later tonight I think I was gonna see my
uncles oh my God
soon and it's going to shoot up and you
can threaten kids right it'll shoot
little little things here's what I'm
gonna win I'm gonna event I'm gonna vet
a steel thing that you drill into your
deck and it dispenses one candy like a
Halloween expenses one candy this is all
covered [ __ ] too
I don't want to touch little kids and I
get it nobody wants to be touching a
bunch of little [ __ ] Rugrats but you
don't have to just [ __ ] have them
yeah
I get it people just want to stay in the
house but then don't do the can yeah
you're right
it's one of the other and the fact that
you're not going out with your kids
you're this 10 year olds going out you
got to go out you're kidding me kids
suck now our generation My Generation we
had morals you got an ass whooping if
you got caught stealing the candy what
looking that's how you get them you got
you never got beat that's why you're
sick man
well you threw your wall you heard one
with a loud voice you threw your water
I've never heard an older person say
that their generation was better before
this is crazy
[Laughter]
um
we're trick-or-treating if I cook more
than one candy I'd get a beaten uh I
don't know I blame both people I bet the
scum because got my kids but the people
who don't who just when you just put a
bowl out you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah
absolutely stay home stay home where are
you where are you on what was it Monday
yeah right where were you where are you
at on the no costume kids taking candy
uh I know you gotta dress up no costume
okay I'll tell you what if you catch
them you should be forced to dress them
in whatever costume you want to put them
yeah black face
wow what if
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
watch Bobby Kelly's special kill box
lewisck.com it's at the top of the
homepage
what piece of [ __ ] that was like let's
move this down
no no I blame Joe list why for his dumb
movie because his shitty movie was on
the top Jesus Christ I mean it's a great
movie and you were really good yeah I've
had three drinks for breakfast no it's a
great movie fantastic I mean Fourth of
July is amazing everything Louie's doing
is he's is great because he's literally
making his own Netflix and then giving
other people opportunities like myself
and Joe so yeah cheers to Louis you're
here yeah all right well thanks let's
plug some of Bobby's tour dates
coming up we got tonight we got uh the
regs Lewis
uh Joe Dan and Nate tonight
and and whenever Lewis CK might stop by
no I'd like to get you guys on at some
time
all right that's great it's so weird
when you ask somebody to do a podcast
you're like I like you'd let you like
really you're like yeah yeah yeah uh
yeah I'm gonna be everywhere comedy
Connection in Rhode Island laugh Boston
that first time in three years they'll
be back in Boston doing a club mic drop
in San Diego off the hook Comedy Club
Tim Gage is opening here Comedy Club
Buffalo ah easy yeah you and Tim Gates
so yeah Bobby Kelly Robert kelly.com
yeah right robertlive.com there you go
rob okay live on Instagram all that [ __ ]
follow me on that I guess that's what
the kids do nowadays remember don't take
all the candy just take one
hour yeah that looks like a Blade Runner
yeah it was James Webb who made that we
love it uh Kansas City coming up Tacoma
Spokane then uh OKC we've removed that
and then the the real tour starts we got
uh St Louis Dallas I don't [ __ ] know
go to Samuel go to the website it's
always honest
uh Jesus Dallas
he has no family do you want a kid
someday oh please I would love to what
yeah I have a kid
I'm a few steps removed from there sure
sure but uh hey let's go one step at a
time I'm literally hitting every city
Boston that's not your website literally
everything
so just go to the website Class Act Mark
you look at Mark does not like being
married he's awake
I mean you hate your wife uh you guys
we're about to take my wife to it
uh yeah I'm in New Haven uh Wilbur New
Orleans
Philadelphia's Nashville Buffalo you you
name it
I like the road I like the road
yes yeah we're married to the Sea
exactly c word and uh
she's very nice she's a good egg and uh
huge tits very lucky guy
trying to express you doing your vows I
love you you're the best queef uh
did you write are you writing your vows
ah I got another comic to write them I
paid them orney Adams yeah
you're good I'm the best
but you're good Bodega cat whiskey.com
buy the whiskey we love you Liz you can
see it would be nice if if we you could
sell it in New York and you could uh oh
Jesus
it'll be here by Christmas
this is awesome good for you guys feel
like you're in money we're trying we're
trying Ryan Reynolds this is yeah I love
talking Ryan Reynolds love him I try to
squeeze him in wherever I can
what was the name of that poem you guys
said when you drank uh it's a w pleasure
W fun W or Vision with Alan's 101.
[Applause]
[Music]
uh NYC on 38th Street and uh Peter
playing NYC for all your hospitality bar
restaurant needs all right Salamanca Liz
anything I'm directing Daniel Simonson's
special
[Music]
November 18th no checks but I hope yeah
all right I love those people comedy
Good Egg great people the best even Anna
if you know if you can please donate to
the Steve King GoFundMe it's uh I mean
buy my special first yes
listen spend ten dollars on Bobby's
special worth it I mean they did he also
spelled
they both killed they should have put a
million
and we'll see you very soon thanks for
listening guys
[Music]
[Music]
we might be true
[Music]